hi in this video I'll talk about not
signalling pathway and this video is an
overview I'm not going to give you
extreme details about the signaling
pathway but I have a different video on
that which would be a lot more details
but in this video what we would learn is
the basic concept behind the knot
signaling and a context in which not
signaling is so important so not
signaling unlike other signaling is very
different because not signaling is a
intercellular signaling so it involves
two cells one cell will express not
which you can think about our extra
cellular receptor and other cell would
express the ligand and this ligand is
known as Delta Delta is very different
from other soluble against Delta is a
transmembrane protein so it's a membrane
bound ligand it's not a soluble ligand
so just like any other signaling pathway
the first step of the signaling is
interaction between this receptor and
ligand that means interaction between
notch and Delta now let us talk about a
little bit about the structure of notch
and Delta both notch and Delta has EGF
repeats in case of not the intracellular
domain contains and guide and repeat and
also a ps/2 domain for its degradation
by each readability realization so when
not and Delta interacts with each other
there is a protease which is known as
Adam Cleaves not at its extracellular
domain and transmembrane domain
interface this particular cleavage type
is known as s2 cleavage as a result not
accessory the domain is freed out but
it's still interacting with the delta
but the other portion is hanging from
the membrane the intracellular domain is
hanging from the membrane it's not free
yet there is another complex known as
gamma secretase which chops off the not
intracellular domain from the
transmembrane domain and as a result in
ICD is free
on the other hand side the knotch and
delta which has which are which has
interacted with each other in the other
cell is about to be in the Saito stay in
a CD can be internalized into the
nucleus it can migrate to the nucleus
inside the nucleus it is known to give
rise to transcriptional changes inside
the nucleus it interacts with mastermind
CFL and CB f1 which are all
co-activators and that leads to define
transcriptional program out of many
target genes of the not signaling
pathway famous ones are p21 cyclin d1 or
C make and if you can understand from
this particular gene name all of these
genes are important for cell division
and cell cycle progression so although
these things lead to cellular
proliferation right and that's why in
context of cancer not signaling is found
to be heavily altered increased not
signaling would increase the cellular
proliferation and lead might lead to
cancer now not signalling is not only
interesting or important in terms of
cancer or disease aspect it is
fundamental signaling underlying
development in case of brain development
we know in mouse brain or in mammalian
brain the ventricular zone zone is
populated with stem cells and they are
in hi they are highly proliferative and
they are basically progenitors for
neurons
now these stem cells are maintained in a
proliferative state by not signaling
that is why when notch is mutated in
those Mouse the stem cells of the
ventricular zone differentiates into
neurons prematurely there is a burst of
neurogenesis and then it's over and that
leads to cognitive impairment in bees
Mouse now in context of immune system
not signalling is very important
especially it is
in context of how peace lrpc lineage
commitment takes place we know that T
cell or B cell everything starts from
hematopoietic you put in stem cells
which give rise to common lymphoid
progenitor now this common lymphoid
progenitor of one hand side it can give
rise to be sales and other hand side it
can give rise to t-cell precursor no T
cell precursor you know would ultimately
give rise to a mature T cell now the
question is when does the lineage
commitment takes place striking
observation from mouse model has shown
that not one gain-of-function Mouse has
all the common lymphoid progenitor
committed to our T cell lineage so the
gain of function leads to T cell fate
whereas in the loss of function or in
the knockout situation you find B cells
present in the thymus in thymus you
would normally expect T cell to the
present but in this notch one
conditional knockout huge amount of P
cells are found in the thymus that mean
all these evidence together such as that
T cell lineage commitments requires not
signalling over several decades of
research now tells us that inside the
thymus there are timing epithelial cell
which interacts with the T cell at its
double negative stage and at this stage
the T cell expressed knotch
whereas the timing material cell express
Delta now this notch and there the
interaction between T cell and thymic
epithelial cell leads to their lineage
commitment and they are never going to
get back to a B cell step from now on
they're committed to become a T cell now
if we compare not signalling with other
signaling pathways like GPCR signaling
or map kinase signaling we would see a
striking difference and the striking
difference is a module ability
apparently you might think that because
G both GPCR signaling and map kinase
signaling has several steps and at
several steps there are opportunity to
modulate the signaling or control the
gain of this signaling but if you look
at the not signaling pathway the NiCd
directly migrate to the nucleus and give
rise to transcriptional changes you
might think that okay not signaling
power
is not that much module able or it's not
fine tunable but this I thought might
not be true it turns out not signalling
is heavily tuned and its game can be
controlled but in a different way so
let's look at it so imagine there are
like different ligands for knotch
receptor and there are different kind of
notch receptor itself right and their
interaction affinity is very different
for example DN l1 and jag one has very
low affinity compared to DLL four and
this differential affinity gives rise to
differential transcriptional programs
which leads to different rate commitment
or different identity in different cells
so two important factors we should
consider which might lead to
differential outcomes one is the
affinity of receptor ligand interaction
and second the time duration by which
the receptor is interacting with the
ligand all these factor or a combination
of both can give rise to different
signaling outcome in order to understand
that better we need to take a live
example from Josefina's in Drosophila
the hares are known as bristle and if we
look in details these hair cells are
actually a combination of four cells
hair cells socket cells seed sale and
neuron now all these thing are born from
a common progenitor which is sensory
organ progenitor which give rise to two
intermediate progenitors which are P to
a and P to B which ultimately gives rise
to all these four cell types now
question is from one single entity how
four different identities could be
produced and how not signaling is
involved in that it turns out in the
sensory organ progenitor a protein numb
is at very high level and it is a
symmetrically distributed and it is
propagated also via a symmetric
deficient so is what happens is numb is
distributed at to the one region of the
protein meter and that's why one of the
daughter gets high level of numb other
daughter gets low level
and it is true for these neurons as well
which has very high level often numb and
it is known that numb inhibits not so if
you look at the progenitor state of
these neuron and the shield cell we
would seen the neuron the number level
is pretty high and as expected notch
level would be low so in the neuron
precursor the delta level would be high
on the other hand side the receiver cell
which is the seed cell which express
knotch now this not signaling in the
receiver cell out of many product it
would first transcribe notch itself and
increase the level of notch but decrease
the level of Delta now if you look at
these two cells we can clearly
understand in the left hand side the
seed cell precursor has higher level of
not compared to the neuron whereas the
neuron has neuronal precursor has higher
level of Delta compared to the seed
Silpa cursor so this differential level
of notch and Delta concentration inside
these cells would ultimately lead to
differential outcome by different
transcriptional programs right and
that's how diversity is generated during
the stages of development
it's a beautiful mechanism which tells
us from one entity how diversity could
be achieved so this was the overview of
this concept I hope you enjoyed this
concept and if you liked this video give
a thumbs up do let me know how you like
my videos and in a second video I'll
talk about all the nuts and bolts of not
signaling so stay tuned thank you